violence in movies and sex
on tv setting aside that there are
clearly both of these things in both
if you were really to separate the two
wouldn't you say sex in movies and
violence on tv it's almost like you're
prioritizing the rhyme scheme here more
than the common sense
are the griffins the type of family to
put up new decorations for the fall and
even if they are being decor shamed by
the family guy is probably a big enough
sin as it is
sponge cow now see that doesn't make any
sense
first cows don't live under the sea let
alone in pineapples
and second his name is bob and he is a
sponge
sponge bob so technically this should be
cowbop which honestly is probably the
name of at least 157 ranchers already
you want to tell me what the hell
happened to our thanksgiving turkey
apparently you deep fried and ate the
entire thing while drunk
that seems like a lot of efforting for a
drunk guy especially this drunk guy
stealing a pumpkin pie maybe but a full
turkey
also why did you put the carcass back in
the refrigerator instead of throwing it
in the trash
even in an episode of family guy that
makes zero sense couldn't she have just
seen it in the trash can instead
arguing with the fridge still open well
if they're expecting a turkey i'll just
put on evan almighty for him even though
they're clearly making fun of it just
simply reminding me that evan almighty
is a movie that exists
is a sin
[Music]
she had a stroke that killed the part of
her brain that says jack robinson we got
plenty of time
stroke jokes no the only thing we really
sell here are these little packets of
weird vitamins
ah sudden h archer bob german what is
wrong with this tuba bell what is that
solid metal ring inside it and why is it
still properly tubing
brian i love training love trains but
still
train hear that this thing's all on you
what what are you talking about
i'm pretty sure we're talking about the
fact that this episode needed three or
four minutes of filler so the z plot
about chris needing to be the man of the
house for thanksgiving was born
you mean like fall asleep on the toilet
and have a big red ring on my bum for a
week
being aware of the color and duration of
your dad's bum ring
hello love let's have a swear
considering mr cap lives in northeast
england why does he have a distinct
london cockney accent and yes
that's the thing about this joke i
decided to point out ass all right bird
i goes by smell why is this hoop in the
middle of the driveway that's not only
the worst place for it for use of the
garage
but it's the worst place for it to even
play basketball there is no indication
that any of these windows were open so
the interior shouldn't be flooded yet
and peter should not be able to open
this door if you're ever in a vehicle
sinking in water open the door window
immediately to let the pressure equalize
so you can escape
see you actually learned something from
a sins video which is probably a sin on
you now that i think about it
and this is a sin for triggering my
jefferophobia and my submechanophobia
did another car come through the
shrubbery after them because there is a
much wider distribution of shrubbery
damage now than there was when they went
through it initially
great the water completely killed my
phone here give me yours
i threw mine at a duck look we all know
you have to conveniently eliminate the
phones from the equation but if it's not
gonna make any sense could you at least
try to make it funny
come to think of it add a little humor
to this show and family guy might
actually make a great sitcom
i hope my dad's not watching abc because
you don't want him to know you're gay or
because you don't want him to see you
get murdered by giant balls for going to
do terribly tasteless gay humor let's at
least have it be a little less confusing
damn it peter that was our only way home
well that's where you're wrong
brian free bus bike that you were only
able to snag because the bus driver
chose to wait until you could get the
whole routine out before taking off
damn it where the hell are they with
that turkey hi
you've reached brian griffin calling
your dog before you call your husband
oh great you broke the chain and now we
have to walk broke it he demolished it
have you ever seen a bike chain
you need to blow torch or bolt cutters
to get through those things even if it
breaks i highly doubt it shatters like
it's been dipped in liquid nitrogen
hi grandma i got some down their hair
now wanna see
completely ignoring the pubic hair
conversation with your grandma
joke i'm going to say why is she leaving
her hand in his mouth
hey you having a good time tonight i
hope he at least paid lucy or two cents
afterwards
can't believe we got robbed and peter
got shot three times
how is he still walking you know what
peter you've got no turkey
and now you've got no friend good-bye am
i actually supposed to care about peter
peter
turkey eater and brian the talking dog's
friendship right now in a show that
features a y2 gay joke and sexual
assault snoopy
just checking now let's watch a whole
bunch of
ads jokes that don't hold up for
physical media or on most streaming
platforms
and actually probably weren't funny in
the first place last year i raised eight
dollars and got on a buzzfeed listicle
proudly exposing your listicles
there's our answer we break into the zoo
steal a turkey bring it home we're
heroes
my favorite part of the zoo experience
is always the turkey exhibit the rails
are off this thing
thing i say five seconds into every
episode of this
show somehow makes it into the script if
the turkeys could fly out of their
habitat this easily why did the zoo
design it like this
this wild turkey chase is on for some
time turkeys do not know how to operate
gondolas i would know i've tried to
train several
they all end up just looking at me or
floating on me but the gondolas never
start
hey it's thanksgiving shouldn't you be
in detroit losing a football game right
now
[Laughter]
brian up here deus ex mckingo
you saved my life course i did you're my
best friend
hey listen skip peter we can't eat a
live turkey well not with that attitude
you can't
well buddy i guess this is it so earlier
the turkey knew to run away from you but
now he's just gonna give you puppy dog
eyes
good thing this bird has such a great
sense of what the plot needs from him
stuffing the turkey without consent the
man of the house
killed a turkey for thanksgiving yeah
but chris was passed out upstairs when
peter and brian got home with the turkey
so
what was the initial reason he was
bringing a shotgun downstairs
seriously this show is secretly darkest
i told you we put it in too early do you
hear the ding in your head when you
watch movies
i hear it all the damn time especially
around the holidays i'm done hiding my
damn dings i'm going to wear them
proudly
like a goddamn youtube grinch if you
want to do the same you can grab this
limited edition monstrosity from our
store
mary dingleus everyone all right pinhead
your time is up hey
good tune man i don't think so
[Music]
yeah here we go
this thing on yes it's not making any
noise yeah it's a real shame you know i
got myself a prius it's a hell of a
machine
you are so stupid stupid you're so
stupid
i immediately regret this decision are
we gonna eat soon
hey how come people don't have dip for
dinner why is it only a snack
stop my penis can only get so erect